thank you so much
thank you so much for that lovely
introduction thank you everyone for
thank you everyone for being here you're
very brave given given what I'm going to
share with you tonight but I promise
we'll go to a very dark and scary place
and then we'll come out into a place of
hope and Forward Thinking yes but I do
admire your courage and before I begin I
just want to
find find the words to express how
grateful I am to Hillsdale College not
only for inviting me but for being what
it is which is truly a light right now
to not just America but to probably the
world in helping us remember what
liberal arts are supposed to do and what
western civilization is supposed to be
for and what it means to actually take
on that incredibly
um
powerful and responsible and sacred task
of overseeing the education of young
adults from the ages of 17 or 18 to 21
or 22 and out of all the institutions
that I've
witnessed in the last three years this
is the only one this is the only one in
which the students have not been
traumatized
[Music]
[Applause]
I I'm so grateful to all of you so I'm
just going to jump right in is there I'm
a Pacer is there a a handheld mic I
might uh use while I pace and oh I'm
sorry Mr Bell
um I I'll stand here till I handheld
manifests so I I should also start out
by disclosing that I did spend my entire
career on the left
I was an advisor to gore 2000 and to the
Clinton reelection I'm sorry I just feel
I should share I should share this I
should get it out I should I should just
be transparent
um and the last three years have shown
me that my former world has truly
imploded and that now yeah
sad but true but the happy part is that
now I think something's happening in
this country in which left and right
really are losing any meaning and what
really matters is what I've found which
is my brothers and sisters are right
here in this room my brothers and
sisters are anyone who cares about the
Constitution Liberty and freedom
so I'm so happy to be with you tonight
um and I should also disclose in case
you're worried this is not a Pharma hit
this I ran after a puppy or we have an
adorable new puppy and he was faster
than I am so
um that's that all right so I'm going to
talk to you about what's really in the
Pfizer documents um and uh if I pace
around like this can you hear me
okay
um and the reason I know what's in the
Pfizer documents is not because I'm a
medical doctor I'm not it's not because
I'm a scientist I'm not I'm an English
major my D Phil is in Victorian poetry
but but I know what's in the Pfizer
documents because something kind of
miraculous in the history of
intellectual inquiry happened to me and
to the world
um as a result and it's the following uh
some of you may know that a lawyer named
Aaron Siri uh
pursued a lawsuit against the FDA to
release
the internal documents that Pfizer uh
created as part of its uh rollout of its
mRNA injection and these are internal
documents showing what happened when
people were injected with this material
and also the experiments that led up to
it internally and thank God for the
judge in that lawsuit because the FDA
asked that judge to keep these documents
hidden for 75 years right until long
after we are all gone
exactly and the judge said no
and so the documents were released
so I read this thank you so much and as
a journalist I was concerned because I
knew that journalists them thank you so
so much
where
are not equipped to as lay people to
understand the technical language in the
documents and I also knew that Pfizer
was releasing 55 000 documents a month
and even that is a bit deceptive because
these are documents that each of them
can be 10 000 pages long right so
massive a massive tranche of of data and
that ordinary journalist who's going to
go into the memory hole unless we found
specialized readers to to read through
analyze and interpret and boil down into
manageable reports thank you so much
what was in the Pfizer documents so
I went on war room which is another
great irony of this moment are we good
thank you so much all right thank you to
this lovely lady who helped me be
audible thank you
thank you I feel free here at Hillsdale
I can go anywhere I can say anything
um
I went on war room which is you know one
of these great ironies of this moment
that Steve Bannon and I have this you
know interlocutory
um platform where he listens to what I
have to say which is a miracle because I
got de-platformed a year and a half ago
um for doing what I've done for 35 years
which is reporting on women's
reproductive and Sexual Health
um in June of 2021 I reported on the
fact that women were experiencing
menstrual symptoms subsequent to
receiving an mRNA injection I'm a
feminist I've been a feminist for ever
my first book was published when I was
26 and it is not unusual for me to call
attention to symptoms that women are
having that are red flags anyone who
knows 8th grade biology can tell if
women are having menstrual symptoms
they're going to be other bad things
happening down the road
um and sure enough Twitter de-platformed
me for this obvious observation and I I
was also smeared globally and it turns
out another lawsuit subsequently found
that it was the White House the CDC
possibly DHS and Twitter all unlawfully
colluding to D platform and smear me for
making this observation about women's
health
yeah but fast forward
um I was talking on war room about the
release of these documents and I called
for experts to help us read through them
and miraculously
2500 experts responded to this call
right yes
yes
but the story is not over because I was
ill-equipped to manage them and so we
had Physicians we had RNs we had
biostatisticians medical fraud invest
investigators lab clinicians research
scientists cardiologists Pathologists
anesthesiologists some of the most
distinguished scientists and medical
people imaginable but it's virtually
impossible to manage 2500 experts around
the world uh especially you know if you
don't have this background waiting
through 55 000 documents a month so
again the reason I tell this story is I
really feel like something
metaphysically beautiful is happening
even in the middle of something
metaphysically hideous and that is this
tiny woman Amy Kelly this tiny doll-like
woman and I stress her tiny doll like
appearance because it's so stereotypical
but she's such a force of nature right
belong those stereotypes she offered to
be our project manager she stepped right
in and she just calmed the storm
and she organized these 2500 experts
immediately 3 500 experts around the
world into six working groups with a
committee at the head of each who were
busy churning out uh reports based on
these primary source documents so that
they could tell the world using the
highest level of analysis possible but
broken down into language that everyone
could understand what was in the Pfizer
documents
so this is just stunning to me that this
happened so now there are 58 reports and
now is the sad part of what I have to
tell you
the Pfizer documents contain evidence of
the greatest crime against humanity in
the history of our species
and I'm so sorry to have to walk you
through this but there's no way around
it we just have to go through and the
beauty of Hillsdale is that
you all are tough and like truth
um and so with truth we can we can
Prevail uh but it's it's it's painful
some of the things that came to light
just some headlines
Pfizer knew for instance one month after
rollout so that's November of 2020 that
the vaccines didn't work to stop covid
indeed in the Pfizer documents a month
after rollout and this is marketing post
marketing so it's it's out there the
spokes models are telling you to do it
the ads are in social media you know the
ads are on television a month after
rollout Pfizer's internal documents
identify that the vaccines have vaccine
failure
and
failure of efficacy and they identify
that the third most common side effect
of the Pfizer vaccine is
covid
the second headline which is stunning is
that within a month or two Pfizer was
getting so many reports of Adverse
Events meaning bad things happening to
people who had been injected that they
understood that they needed to hire
2400 full-time staffers in order simply
to process the paperwork of the Adverse
Events that they were receiving reports
of as well as to prepare for the flood
of Adverse Events that they knew they
would get in the near future
Pfizer knew in May of 2021
that the vaccines had caused heart
damage in 35 minors within a week after
the injection and yet and Pfizer knew
right you've got to understand that all
of these documents say FDA confidential
at the bottom of them right Pfizer and
the FDA shared these documents and the
FDA knew that 35 miners sustained heart
damage but the government of the United
States and I'm embarrassed to say I
voted for these people didn't tell
parents until August of 2021 that there
was an elevated risk of heart damage in
healthy young adults four months later
and in those four months what did the
young adults of America receive
a constant battering with propaganda on
social media on television in news
outlets bought up by money in the cares
act as well as from the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation with like influencers
showing off their injection site saying
you know we can do this together we can
be strong do it for Grandma all of this
aimed at young adults they did not tell
the young adults the healthy young
adults of the United States your
generation
that this was elevating a risk of heart
damage
till four months later
you may recall that the CDC said that
the materials of the injections stay in
the injection site and the materials are
lipid nanoparticles they are mRNA and
the lipid nanoparticles are an
industrial fat which is covered in
polyethylene glycol which is a petroleum
byproduct right and Spike protein well
the CDC said it stays in the injection
site and then it says and I remember
asking doctors like relatives who are
doctors and were funded by NIH grants
where does the spike protein go
and they were like you know when you're
a journalist you've got an ear for
nonsense they were like well your body
metabolizes it you know or well you'll
digest it and excrete it and it's like
they had no evidence to give me to show
me
the basis for their response but in fact
that's not what happens to these
materials and Pfizer knew that these
materials
biodistribute this is Pfizer's language
throughout your body in 48 hours and
where do they settle they well lipid
nanoparticles are designed to cross
every membrane in the human body they've
known this for 10 years
so where do these these ingredients go
they go to the brain some of you have
noticed changes in the personalities of
loved ones who have taken these
injections
they biodistribute to the liver the
adrenals the spleen and if you're a
Woman They accumulate in your ovaries
now these are industrial fats coated
with polyethylene glycol in your ovaries
okay
and what's really scary Dr Robert
Chandler who's a respected
um pathologist who's treated uh the
Lakers and the angels he wrote this
report and he shows that the chart shows
the graph going down as it leaves the
injection site but going up as it
accumulates in these various organs over
time and what's incredibly scary if
you're a woman is that there's no
mechanism that we've found by which the
body gets rid of the lipid nanoparticles
in the ovaries
so your first injection some go into
your ovaries your second injection more
go into your ovaries your booster more
go into your ovaries there's no
mechanism with which the body can
release this material that we've seen